ce dimanche 19 janvier les jaunes de
plaisir recevait les verts de
rambouillet deux équipes à la lutte pour
le maintien en d2 de district après
quelques minutes d'observation les
rambos lite un ouvre la marque mais
plaisir revient au score grâce à ce tir
en angle fermé 1 partout un électrochoc
pour les visiteurs qui arrivent à
marquer deux fois avant la mi-temps 3-1
pour rambouillet à la pause aujourd'hui
très réaliste 400 cocasse trois buts
voilà c'est il faut s'adapter tous les
dimanches au match aujourd'hui on s'est
bien adapté on a réussi à concrétiser ce
qu'il fallait c'est parfois un peu
compliqué tactiquement
derrière on était patron place du coup
on a laissé un peu d'espoir ils ont pu
trouver en profondeur dans le dos est
clairement n'est pas rentré dans le
match comme il fallait
non les efforts ils étaient pas que ça
soit devant derrière au milieu de
terrain
ah non moi je sois présent en deuxième
période plaisir revient avec de
meilleures intentions le bloc défensif
et plus haut et c'est grâce aux coups de
pied arrêtés que les joueurs plaisir wav
on revenir au score 2 corner décisif 3 3
à 15 minutes de la fin du match malgré
quelques situations dangereuses les deux
équipes se séparent sur un match nul
spectaculaire
je pense qu'on aurait pu gagner très
franchement en tout cas c'est le
sentiment que j'avais sur le banc de
touche maintenant un compte tenu de la
physionomie du match je le répète un le
score
mais score nul et au fait quand même je
pense la physionomie du match 2e mi
temps le discours c'est de pas flanché
justement ils vont rentrer avec d'autres
intentions un peu plus costaud gagner
les duels et c'est ce qui s'est passé on
peut espérer gagner le match
je pense pas qu'ils puissent gagner le
match mais le match nul n'est pas
immérité c'est pas mal ce résultat
n'arrange aucune des deux équipes dans
la course au maintien rambouillet
toujours neuvièmes du classement et
plaisir 10e
la prochaine journée est programmée ce
dimanche 26 janvier